we consider the case where an object is
moving on the surface but now let's
consider what happens that if we apply a
force at here and the object stays at
rest well we still have the normal force
distributed over this surface but now
because the object is at rest there's
another con the contact force now is
what we call static friction the
tangential part of that and the contact
force is still the perpendicular part
the normal force plus the tangential
part which we referred to as static
friction now what happens with static
friction is that if we don't apply a
force at all then there's no static
friction and in fact you can see in this
simulation that if we slowly increase
the applied force then the static
friction force gets bigger and bigger it
depends on what we're doing to the
system but at a certain point when we
apply a large enough external force the
object suddenly starts to slip that's
what we call the just slipping condition
and the reason for that is static
friction has reached its maximum
possible value that has to do with the
physics of the interaction between the
surface and the object so also there's a
very subtle thing is that as you see
when we pull the force and it just slips
suddenly the friction has gone from
static to kinetic friction and it's
gotten a little bit smaller how do we
express those properties well what we
have is the idea that the static
friction can vary in magnitude between
zero and some type of maximum value
depending on the other constraints on
the system and the maximum value of
static friction we have a force law
which is that it's again proportional to
the normal force but the coefficient is
called now the coefficient of static
friction
and this coefficient of static-friction
is slightly bigger than the coefficient
of kinetic friction which explains why
that arrow got a little bit smaller when
it just started to slip now again like
kinetic friction static friction is
opposing this external force and
depending on the direction that the
object moves for instance if we applied
the external force in the opposite
direction here then the static friction
that's distributed over the surface is
opposing that force but there may be
many systems in which we're actually not
quite sure which way static friction
points and as the course develops and we
look at more complicated examples we'll
see that the direction of static
friction can depend on all the other
constraints on the system